happy Halloween citizens of the reject
Nation we are here and it is time to
check out Michael Myers in the final
definitely absolutely never coming back
again Halloween film Halloween ends but
before we go into that I'm joined by our
very good friend Andrew Gordon of the
movie Source Channel Andrew how are you
doing today I'm doing well it's
Halloween I'm entitled to one good scare
that's right and hey we mustn't forget
that evil dies tonight it does it does
it does or perhaps after a time Jump I
don't know much about this movie other
than I've heard the responses are all
over the place which gets me very
excited I liked the 2018 version I did
not like Halloween kills all that much
we just want it to be better than the
1978 version that's all we're asking
that's really the bars pretty low but
anyway if you guys could go ahead and
leave a like on this video leave a
comment with your thoughts on Halloween
ends the franchise as a whole we would
love to hear from you also subscribe hit
that notification Bell and if you want
to get the full experience come on over
to our patreon page patreon.com the real
rejects you can sync up with us with
your own copy of Halloween ends enjoy
all the little moments that don't make
it to the reaction and we also got a
bunch of other exclusives over there
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included and finally big big
thank you to the prepper people cutting
down these highlights it is a task and
we appreciate them very much uh that's
all the housekeeping it's it's time it's
it's finally here the end of the
Halloween franchise are you ready Andrew
I'm ready then let's get to it
foreign
[Music]
music's really setting the tone I like
it I'm here for it I like a good
Halloween party Vibe you know sorry this
is loud
it literally just caught me Rogers come
party and I could care less about it
it's not Halloween without Toccata and
Fugue
we are
Jeremy
it's a creepy staircase
[Laughter]
no TV you guys can play till 8 30 8 45
then you should go to bed
easy money yes
that sounds like a threat it's Halloween
we're gonna have a good time tonight no
all right
[Music]
oh my God paying respects to John
Carpenter you just saw this for the
first time look at that Pokemon's Gonna
Get You
he's not gonna get me
those babysitters not kids
oh
uh he does kill kids in this universe
too though yeah asked the kid who wanted
to dance
wow dude
five minutes and then you're going to
bed you sucking babysitting I'm not a
babysitter
doesn't strike me as interesting it's
like you rarely see a boy babysitter
I've done it before
I would let you babysit my kids thanks
John all five of my kids
uh
this isn't funny Jeremy
man he didn't even take the milk Jeremy
come on
[Music]
dang okay let me out are you scared okay
Jeremy let me out
oh boy
I'm gonna kill you Jeremy
oh no
oh
no wow
oh God
[Music]
oh my God that's not what I was
expecting
[Music]
whoa a subversion of expectations and
the and the blue font like like
Halloween three like a Season of the
Witch Michael Myers was pure evil
he took our dreams and turned them into
nightmares
oh
40 years later he escaped
and Haddonfield was once again forced to
confront this man in a mask
[Music]
that sucks Michael Myers was the
personification of evil
[Music]
it's their wedding ring oh
you're late again
so I guess he retired from being a
babysitter yeah he's not gonna get
another gig pretty anytime soon I'm
watching kids hey uh Ronald
thanks
no problem kid that guy's gonna die
horribly I'm gonna be sad when it
happens he's gonna die in the compactor
like a little Child's Play Three action
the best child's play Oh by far we're
seniors okay we've been practicing for a
show the whole year you know loading up
for uh tonight's game
you know
his face there
that's right right so where's your next
event
[Music]
would you look at this I mean a psycho
meets a fruit show wow this is a match
made in heaven hey come on for now let's
go y'all if anyone deserved to die
oh oh
so do you want to do it
you want me to
oh yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
and in 2022 those are cheap to replace
[Laughter]
this gentleman had an accident
it was a creepy look
hey there you gonna feel a little bit of
a pinch here
cute isn't she
sorry sorry no no my fault
I'm so sorry a mess this guy's gonna
become the accident prone Michael Myers
he's gonna have like a killing spree
based off of mishaps alone
so your job sucks where do you work
we should go out sometime and do
something with me
with both of us
Oh no I got the death card no that just
means a major phase is ending and a new
one is about new beginning that pretty
much puts a nail in the coffin with that
police officer you were dating what you
really don't want is the Tower
that is a scary card someone that can
let go that makes you want to rip off
your shirt and show grief your
son say you know what let's go this is
delicious
good transition sure yeah who's that
person you're texting
that's normal I didn't see them exchange
numbers did you plot hole she got it
from the hospital
someone's dying in that compactor icon
no dude
questions how many people left hand is
your uh clutch right foot is your back
brake and uh left foot is the shifter
thingy so
it doesn't sound
like don't worry
the car he put it on my goddamn stunt
drove three miles on the clock because
it doesn't know how to change a tire on
a goddamn automobile
ah see he's a victim of circumstance he
wouldn't be such a jerk if his pops
wasn't such a jerk like how his dad
slapped him in public
you know she's been talking to the sky
you probably know him Corey Cunningham
oh yeah he's a good kid I had a tough
break it's nice to know somebody's out
there looking out for him
Cunningham oh Sean s Cunningham yep I
understood that reference I just got my
license I'm sorry I'm sorry I don't
understand do you see what he did to my
sister he killed her husband oh she's
still alive oh [ __ ] you tempted and you
provoked that man when you should have
left him alone
I can't believe she survived that call
James a Denise gonna have to update that
kill count you okay
I would like to see those cherry
blossoms and I think you'd like them too
that's not the first time they read kind
of death in this series because will
Patton's character we all thought he
died in the 2018 version two from Dr
certain absolutely
the Sanderson sisters are going to be
singing Here Right sisters
the the sandersons could take down
Michael Myers oh for sure that's a
battle we need to see now that's the
versus movie we we never knew we wanted
but we absolutely deserve
definitely
ah the devil Halloween five remember the
girl in the devil costume there's
another reference
[Music]
yeah see anything you like like the OG
Michael Myers cameos
I wonder if that's the same bar from
Halloween kills probably with their
knack for bringing everything back I
wouldn't be surprised
it's probably the most fun this guy's
had in literal years
oh
geez
evil evil dies tonight and you think you
can fix me but you can't let's bury the
heartache
excuse me
no
romance dies tonight
[Laughter]
oh is it these kids again no oh the best
kids I want to apologize handshakes and
friendship
don't leave him hang into it
oh
yeah Dollar Store designer friends no
hate when people crush the glasses
damn he fell well busted him is he dead
go down and look you go down I didn't
push nobody he fell [ __ ] he fell
that's my story
get in the car Margo kill the kid man
why are you still hanging with them
uh
that's such a creepy image now it's the
Jason remake
oh damn whoa
[Applause]
sleep
[Music]
that was a [ __ ]
[Music]
hey pass all his knowledge down to him
well you can survive anything downloaded
The Matrix of murder into his mind
I'm Michael Myers
zombies
oh geez
oh no
oh no
this guy's just always in the wrong
place at the wrong time I know
you should have wiped that thing off
before you threw it bro no hard feelings
about the promotion right of course you
deserve it I thought for sure Dr Mathis
is going to make you the charge nurse
jeez have a little humility yeah she was
excited for the promotion no hard
feelings I thought you were gonna get it
oh no
oh
jeez
waiting for Allison
scare you I just hid
say that I'm sorry I just
no excuse but if you could please you
could just take a walk with me
oh
she's getting psycho Vibes bruh I'm
sorry I lost mad at the party and I
walked away
that was a mistake you told me that you
want to burn it down
would you tell me you want to burn it
hey
oh oh no the cop hey the sponge cake you
two want to stop by get a slice after
whatever you guys are doing good okay
you're good let me tell you to change
your mind she said we're good Allison
so you call Mr aggravated manslaughter
at night when you can't sleep
you feel safe
Everyone's an [ __ ] this town no
your heart
all right Lori knew I didn't trust that
car
God if only it was Lori I have a feeling
it's
one of the cops or something huh could
be
good oh John my man
Jesus
no no
oh he's definitely cracked
whoa that's awesome
yeah
oh that was a cool shot
[Music]
oh damn
really able to just kick off Michael
like that I mean Michael is pushing like
70 still
get up
okay okay no one's ever talked to me
like this before cool it kid
it's all like oxidated
[Music]
I you're the power of murder
[Music]
feels good
he's showing lots of signs of a man you
should not date
nah this is perfectly healthy trauma
bonding
[Music]
here we go he's like I'm too decrepit to
fight you Lori yeah
girl falls for local creep imagine if
your grandmother had fallen in love with
Michael Myers Everyone's an [ __ ] in
this town
as much as people dog the Rob Zombie
movies for explaining Michael it does
feel like Haddonfield is full of shitty
people I can't really blame him for
turning out this way
let's find a way to forgive this kid
and I pull up next to him and he looks
at me
and it's not him oh at least not in the
eyes
I don't know man
the hair is on the back of my neck stood
up huh
kid who used to mow our lawn didn't kill
my son I know that the guy saw on the
side of the road
was done a dark path it was Pure Evil
clean up take a shower
in fact I'll meet you in there
[Music]
yes it's you leave but I love to watch
you go
holy [ __ ] is there a doctor in the house
[Laughter]
Dr Mathis
who's stuck on him Dr Mathis
[Music]
damn
wants his girl to get a promotion
[Music]
[Music]
ah
stick around oh yeah it's one of his
classic kills oh Bob from the first one
yeah
man I thought that was going to be Corey
and Michael on the bike
[Laughter]
it will be by the end okay
this dumb [ __ ] right here everyone's
amazing and hadn't feeling I love them I
want to live here yeah I'll get the hell
up off my property
haha I've never wanted to see Michael
murder so many people in my life
okay
there's a couple scenes off when she was
gonna surveil them
I can smell her on you she's trying to
take you away from me oh God that's
where you go every night
well I say
go
you go right now all right kill your mom
let's go oh what the hell no oh geez
whoa whoa okay that was a weird scene
yeah
you can't have her Allison is not
equipped for this relationship so stay
the away you started this you brought me
in you invited me you want to do it or
you want me to I have a prediction here
you secretly oh Michael comes back for
you
[Music]
on the psycho you're the freak Show
ah call back to the gas station
don't forget who's the master here yeah
and I only imagine
now
[Applause]
oh he got it damn
that was hard
barely an inconvenience
it's like I taught him too much the same
thing in him that I saw in Michael
Michael Myers is who you are you're not
listening to me Allison I am trying to
protect you I don't want your protection
you want me to believe you
hysteria that you caused when I trusted
you
Your Friends Are Dead my parents are
dead you're the one
it's capable of your heart
God where'd he go come out Corey
boy I just want to kiss and make up my
man come on a lockdown here with you
you're locked in here with me
come on Billy let's get this Punk let's
go God Billy Billy what are you trying
to do man suck your own oh my God
Billy's dead
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
I Don't Wanna Be Your Monkey Wrench
foreign
[Music]
oh Jesus Christ no no
oh damn wow that was a good disappear
though
somebody else
oh my
wow whoa whoa
[Music]
that reminded me of the Dr Sartain kill
yeah no compactor what gives
ashamed of yourself exploiting these
tragedies there are three missing people
right now in Haddonfield
called him an ugly mother ether
Nietzsche also said without music life
would be a mistake he's gonna show him
some Kung Fu right that's right
[Music]
and wurg giving Michael the urge right
now
come on
respect for doing the vinyl
oh whoa whoa
that that was a specific kill he's like
watch your tongue when you talk to me
from now on sure oh my God oh my God
oh my God
oh
Finger Licking Good
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
I'm sorry for what I said
I'm sorry
I'm
sorry
please
and I just want you to come home
oh geez yeah
I've embraced my Michael Myers I'm not
good
surprise she doesn't have a crazy
arsenal of weapons like she did in the
first film no she's left that life
behind
yeah there's no way this fixture here
spins around to reveal a rack of guns
and she fights better when she's drunk
anyways
yes I would like to report a suicide oh
no
it's like dude you don't need to attack
just give like 30 more seconds
[Music]
oh did you really think I killed myself
[Laughter]
interesting
to have compassion and find Mercy
foreign
did you really think that Allison
you if I can't ever
done
oh no oh no no no no no no
what did you do to him
[Applause]
I guess she missed the part where the
Michael Myers I guess was right next to
him yeah I guess so
oh foreign
[Music]
suicide
foreign
just like the first film hiding in the
closet
hopefully the microwave noise yep
oh
wow
oh geez
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
I need a point yes
right to the neck again knitting kills
leave my mask on
[Music]
up here
[Music]
reminds me of H2O when she had him
pinned with the car yeah
oh
that has a push out
[Music]
wow
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
I've run from you
I have chased you
I've even killed you once before I have
tried to forgive you I thought maybe you
were the boogeyman
you're just a man
who's about to stop breathing
evil dies tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow look at that face
enough
no oh
I'm not gonna let this happen to you
[Music]
Michael
Eastern
not dead enough
now it goes in the trash compactor
this is not how it works
it is tonight
evil dies tonight
[Music]
I guess everyone got the word that they
had Michael Myers it's the murder Day
Parade man
for 40 years Michael terrorizes down 45
years now however long 44 buddy
[Music]
oh
oh
our favorite character from the 2018
film what was his name Julian yeah my
nasty ass toenails yeah yeah best line
in the movie my favorite babysitter
wow
foreign
needs to go to the hospital or anything
nah she's done that enough times
got it it's like reverse Spider-Man 2.
guess everyone in Talent from [ __ ]
to uh let's join together in solidarity
yeah
ah we got our compact kill yes evil gets
crushed into a cube tonight
[Music]
wow
he definitely survived that yeah he'll
be back
reports now confirmed that Michael Myers
has indeed been killed dead after an
attempted assault to have had to feel
rested into Glory stroke what an
incredible story of certified through
Decades of disturbances
[ __ ] you got the promotion now yeah
New Beginnings lay ahead we just need to
kill Michael Myers now we'll leave
Haddonfield and we decide when to
surrender
I've said goodbye to my Boogeyman
[Music]
but the truth is evil doesn't die
tonight I wanted you to know I was
thinking about you
I want to thank you for what you did
enjoy
go see the cherry blossoms come on what
was it you were saying about those
cherry blossoms
[Music]
foreign
thought they would have shredded that
too
[Music]
but now they're gone
now you got me thinking about the Chucky
show
all right well Andrew yes Donald what
did you think of Halloween end that was
just as brilliant as the curse of
Michael Myers your favorite Halloween
yes yes my favorite one address 1995.
um Andrew's probably seen all the
Halloween films more times than I have
although I think I've seen slightly
there's there's just what one you
haven't seen well I didn't see Rob
Zombie's Halloween 2 uh so that was the
only one but I know about the White
Horse though this has been an
interesting experience because I didn't
read much going into this movie I made
sure to stay fresh I heard a couple
opinions and a couple references and
that was it but one thing I fitted
joying over the past couple of days is
that
you know if anybody knows me they know
I'm a big Rob Zombie fan in a Big Rob
Zombie Halloween fan so it's been very
gratifying to see Rob Zombie trending on
Twitter and so many people being like
man after Halloween ends people better
start putting some respect on Rob
Zombie's name and uh as much as I'm
happy about that sentiment going around
just just personally uh I I actually
didn't uh I didn't dislike this it was
okay for me it was okay just it felt a
little misguided
um okay for me um again I didn't hate
this movie
I just want to tell them most of the
comments remember like he hated this
movie it was it was all right I mean uh
it was not what I was expecting it was
definitely subversion of expectations I
mean from the ending of Halloween kills
again a movie is not bad because it's
not what I was expecting I'm just saying
what what I was expecting going into
this again not watching any of the
trailers or anything but from the ending
of Halloween kills I was expecting Lori
and Allison and Frank will Patton's
character and even uh Kyle Richards
character uh what's uh what's Kyle
Richards uh character's name from the
original film uh everyone knows who I'm
talking Lindsay right sure the Wallace
girl the wall oh yeah yeah yeah anyways
I I was kind of expecting more of uh
like a Revenge Type of hey we're gonna
get Michael for what he did like I mean
especially for Lori so
from that perspective it was definitely
different than what I was expecting and
I like some of the ideas in this you
know because as we pointed out like 900
times in our reaction the people of
haddonfielders they're lovely they're
sweet they're very caring they're
endearing they're very nice to to one
another and surprised the whole town is
not full of Michael Myers but no the
whole idea of Corey it's an interesting
idea and I guess the last time we saw
something like that being you know
possibly thought about was with Jamie
Lloyd at the end of Halloween four and
then they kind of just abandoned that in
Halloween five like no which is just
gonna retcon that we're not winning
We're not gonna do it we're just gonna
go back to Michael after watching this
movie I can see why they possibly didn't
do that
um it didn't I mean again it still had
the spirit of Halloween of course with
that I think the part I loved the most
was the ending just because it that felt
the most Halloween to me with uh Lori
versus Michael we got that final that
Showdown bow but I will say it was
definitely
different and interesting watching
seeing Michael old and decrepit and like
you know not being his his usual self in
you know this rampant of Destruction uh
and kind of Pat passing on the mantle
but again the the idea of what Society
can do to you and just how people
tormenting you the psychology of it
there are some interesting things that
were said in this film that I could
appreciate and can understand you know
from Corey's perspective and I could
understand why again sympathize with
what he has done not you know not root
for him in any way of course it was
awful what he was doing but I could
sympathize and understand where he was
coming from why this happened so from
that perspective I thought that was well
executed I just don't know if that's
what I wanted to see in this Halloween
film but I guess I appreciate them
trying something different again just it
just didn't work for me personally I
didn't hate it or anything it just
didn't work for me as a Halloween film
that's just me but I appreciate them
trying to do something different yeah
it's funny the the further the this
movie got the more I got this feeling of
like I am I'm very fascinated and
excited to discuss this with people
because I have a feeling that they're I
already get the sense that there are a
lot of different opinions and I could
see how you might really like this and
how you might really dislike this and
and I'm of a couple minds and it's funny
to me because uh one there were two
references I heard going into this
somebody said it it gave them a
Christine Vibe and somebody said It felt
more like a scream Sequel and I can
understand both of those kind of
comparisons uh and yeah
I didn't go into this movie with very
many expectations I kind of left
Halloween kills and was just like you
know I'm sure they're gonna do something
or other I'm sure it's gonna be a little
bit different from that because
Halloween kills is different from
Halloween 2018 in certain ways as well
um so I didn't spend too much time
thinking about what is this movie gonna
be other than you know a slasher movie
and so for me it's like I can definitely
fathom this not being what people want
or expected partly because yeah like you
said uh early on during the reaction
it's like kind of the longest it takes
to get to Michael and you have to really
care about the character of Allison and
Corey here especially
um because even Lori like Lori is I
think well used and presented here like
you know Halloween kills and an end with
Halloween too even like she's in the
hospital she's not
as actively affecting the plot itself
and here I thought they split the
difference where it's like yeah there's
a lot of time we're not spending with
Lori but there is a lot of significant
time spent with her and yeah when it
finally comes down to her and Michael
that felt appropriately culminative for
a Halloween movie but being that this is
Halloween ends I could see certain
people being like we spent all this time
on you know these two new characters who
maybe you're not that invested in or
something like that
um and so yeah I feel like that line is
going to be different for everybody and
I'm actually sitting here kind of
surprised for myself because I enjoyed
this much more than I expected to I
Halloween Halloween 2018 when I
Revisited that before Halloween kills I
I expected not to like it as much and I
actually wound up appreciating it about
as much as I did the first time maybe
even a bit more I I rather liked it and
uh Halloween kills I
I definitely did not bring back the same
Goodwill it definitely kind of uh pushed
me off to the other side where it was
like oh this is this is so repetitive
and ridiculous and and kind of silly now
and you know slasher movies often Teeter
on that edge and here I in in a nut in
an isolated uh scenario uh I'll have to
step back and think about this you know
in terms of the pantheon because it's a
big deal too ostensibly end series like
this but from from where I was sitting
just as a movie on its own I was
actually pleasantly surprised that we
were taking so much time to really
develop Allison she's been a part of the
past you know a few movies but this one
seemed like it really cleared the way
for her to you know uh
she's not the central character but she
you know I I would argue I guess Corey's
the central character for a lot of this
but I thought that she was well realized
and she grounded everything really
nicely and the Corey story as much as it
I can I can imagine it would be a lot
for certain folks to swallow I did at
least appreciate I really really liked
the scene where they talked to uh little
Jeremy's dad and he says yeah where he's
like look I I tried to give him the
benefit of the doubt and I even believed
that like my wife you know uh though
understandable her position is you know
I I tried to even look past that and and
say look I really was an accident I want
to forgive this guy and maybe help him
you know past this point and yeah the
kid who was babysitting my son that
night didn't kill him but whoever he is
now isn't the same guy like I thought
that was good and I thought uh Rowan
Campbell did a really good job across
the movie of
starting out charming and starting out
as somebody you very much sympathize for
and can relate to and then becoming
slowly somebody who you're very
horrified by and he does embody that
sort of yeah there's something wrong and
his eyes kind of quality and so as much
as I feel like there's also the aspect
that you have to acknowledge like
Michael's been living in this sewer hole
for like four years and uh I guess is
just kind of really rubbing off on this
dude like again I can see that being one
of those Christine elements where it's
like oh maybe this is a little much for
folks to handle but in a way I enjoyed
his whatever plot holes you can identify
aside I kind of enjoyed that descent
into the madness surprised I wasn't
living in his house anymore I guess
Little John Big John didn't pay off that
mortgage but uh yeah no um yeah no you
made some very good points I will say
two again just I'm trying not to focus
on the negatives just things that are
just coming to my mind right now there
were a lot of scenes where I'm like
a lot of awkward stuff was going on like
when the mom slapped him and then just
if I thought she kissed him on the mouth
and then yeah I mean there were a lot of
awkward moments I felt too that led to
nowhere I mean I get where they were
going with that scene but the
relationship too between you know Corey
and Allison I really understand what
they were trying to do with that I just
felt like everything and again I I can
understand where she was coming from she
the loss of all her friends the loss of
her parents she's in a very emotional
vulnerable place and she felt she could
relate to someone and this was the guy I
totally get that totally understandable
I just felt like everything was
happening so quickly and this guy was
showing so many different signs that
he's not in a position to be in a in a
relationship like this and just a lot of
red flags and she was just continuously
looking beyond that Beyond like I know
when he said I killed someone he was
talking about the kid so that one I that
one I get obviously but some of the
other stuff I mean just like the dude
was just like again red flag after red
like I'm like I get it I get what
they're going for I get that again she
can sympathize and relate to this guy
and you know that's why she's so into
him I get all that totally
understandable human reaction and
emotion but
no there was just too many red flags for
me and then just again to just jump on
his bus when like he said oh your
grandma's trying to kill me and then
just like oh yeah yeah I just believe
you I don't care what my grandma said
it's like I know I know her grandma is
paranoid especially from what we learned
in 2018 when they did have a close
relationship uh Allison and Lori but I
mean she is a drunk and all that stuff
but just to take this guy's word for it
you've been on two or three dates and
he's asking you to move ahead I'm like
I can suspend disbelief but there are
some stuff here like I'm not saying that
can't happen in real life I mean people
you know when when heart when love and
romance is involved sometimes he just
knock sense out of it but there were
just sometimes I'm like Alice what are
you doing yeah it it it's in the it
butts up against certain things because
in the presentation of the movie it
creates this bubble around them where
it's like okay they are two people who
can understand each other in a way few
other people can and it also helps that
most people we see in Haddonfield are
kind kind of shitty in this movie kind
of yeah and I feel like that could have
tempered things a little bit if we had
and I I appreciate the the movie doing a
certain amount to show yeah public
perception people don't understand
people don't take it seriously people
take it very seriously like there's a
little bit of everything but most of the
interactions with anybody else in
Haddonfield safer like Corey's dad are
pretty negative and so
that I think in the immediate experience
of watching the movie helps to create
that again bubble around Allison and
Corey but uh yeah in a more
realistically presented town with better
adjusted people you would be like I feel
like you might pick up some of these red
flags although again you like
with all the the trauma both of these
people have suffered and all the Death
they've gotten close to yeah again like
I wasn't as bugged by it but I also
really can't argue against that point I
guess in this iteration of Haddonfield
board 99.9 people are pieces of shits
and [ __ ] she's like you know what
he's the lesser of that so he's like not
as bad even all these red flags I'm
gonna take my chances with this guy well
I said during the reaction I do think
it's funny in this movie maybe even more
so than Halloween kills because
Halloween kills I think is arguably the
most brutal of the three blumhouse ones
in terms of Michael oh yeah Michael in
that movie is the dark malevolent core
and like the the murders are pretty Grim
in that movie
and here uh uh you know a little less so
there's certainly Carnage for sure but
but it's the first time time during
these three because again like being a
fan of the Rob Zombie movies I think
it's funny that like the Blum House ones
have kind of Taken aspects that worked
for many people for the most agreeable
aspects of Rob Zombie's movies which is
the sort of scuzzy uh harshness of the
kills and then mixed it with the John
Carpenters Halloween aesthetic the more
patient the more lurking the more
stalking the more you know slow Zoom
kind of thing and uh and this was the
first time I was like you know in the
Rob Zombie one yeah Michael grows up
around a very dysfunctional just
Haddonfield and watching this movie I
was like yeah Haddonfield seems like a
pretty dysfunctional place I could
totally see how Michael Myers would have
come out of this place and so it felt
like having that explanation that people
don't like back in the mix Michael Myers
really works for the League of Shadows
he's just cleansing had that field and
you know he works for Raza al Ghul but
you know it's kind of interesting too
I'm kind of curious because we saw that
there were four writers working on this
David Gordon green Danny McBride and the
other two writers that I cannot remember
at the time right now of saying this but
you know at the end of Halloween kills
especially with the great scene we got
at the in the hospital where you know uh
Lori is explaining how Michael is this
malevolent force and we get that scene
with her and Frank and the I really feel
like I thought I thought that Frank was
going to be a bigger part of this film I
feel like he was really pushed to the
side and I get why again you got Corey
you got Allison was you know a lot
bigger role in this film and Michael was
kind of pushed to the sideline a little
bit in this film but I'm really curious
to see what the first you know their
first draft was if Frank was this
sideline because I was really expecting
him to have a much bigger role at the
end of Halloween kills especially if
they kind of really again I I presume
most of us if not all of us thought he
he died in Halloween 2018 when Dr
sardine that sardine uh you know stuck
him in the neck I thought he did at
least so I thought he was gonna have a
much bigger role in this film but and
again that does I'm not saying that took
away my enjoyment or what I did enjoy
this film but I'm really curious what
the first draft was if he had a bigger
more integral part of this of the plot
but because he's barely in the movie I
want to know how many drafts this went
through before they arrived at and
agreed on this particular take because
again like it does feel like one of many
possible outcomes minus a couple things
and I've said this uh about other movies
before where it's like I feel like when
you have especially a sequel that has a
lot riding on it it
you can fall into two categories or
somewhere in between where it's being a
sequel or being V SQL or an ending
versus the ending and there are moments
in this movie like when Lori is having
that final showdown with Michael kind of
anything with Lori uh does feel like the
finale but there is a lot of other stuff
that just feels like you know a story
for this finale uh having said that I
did appreciate at least what we did get
with Frank and the way they built off of
that from the previous movie and yeah
while I would certainly have been happy
to have had a bigger involvement from
him I do like the way they extrapolated
that connection he has with Lori and
their little meat cutes and the way that
they're still kind of awkward after that
situation you know it's not like they
all of a sudden happily ever after it
out of the hospital
um and so yeah at least for the the
character beats for um for Lori and for
Frank I I liked them together quite
quite a lot yeah I agree they had good
chemist history together on screen
chemistry but the reason also too I say
I thought Frank would have a little more
role is the the great flashbacks we got
in Halloween kills where it showed like
he stopped uh Donald pleasence's Dr Sam
Lewis or whoever the actor was that that
played the the the DH so I thought the
tech manager or something like that yeah
whoever was but again they showed that
uh Frank's uh you know Frank was the cop
that stopped Dr Loomis from putting the
final bullet into Michael's head so
that's why I thought maybe he was gonna
have a little more of an intrical part
but again you make you make some good
points there about him one other little
thing that not little thing but other
thing that bothered me too the those
those group of four kids who were really
bullying Corps and not all them I know
was more the the two males uh as opposed
to the other the two females of the
group
the two women kept on continue saying
why are you bullying this guy like no
stop you have three still keeping yet
they still keep hanging out with these
two guys knowing like how terrible these
two people are like why are you still
hanging out with them continuously and
and keep on going on with their
Shenanigans all right
don't do this Tim don't do this oh well
we're hanging tomorrow though okay cool
I don't know just but I guess like again
in a town in this shitty it's like well
I guess you're an [ __ ] but you're not
as big an [ __ ] some of the other
people so I'll still hang out with you
but yeah I guess the buck stops it like
well we we we encouraged him to knock it
off and uh if he doesn't well you know
that's his choice is how it feels from
them but yeah I I get you it would be
and and again I mean like there's not
all the Time in the World to spend
developing all these characters of
course of course just little nitpicks
that got like usually when when I'm
loving a film nitpicks like that I'm
like ah just let it go I don't those
don't bother me yeah for sure for sure
the less you're enjoying the more
glaring all any and all nipples and
again I'm not saying I wasn't enjoying
the film was paced fine and you know
there were some stuff in here that I
appreciate some some uh social
commentary messages I did enjoy but
again there was some stuff that from a
Halloween film and Halloween fan just
for me me not saying for all of you for
me that I felt could have been done
better could have been executed better
or just changed entirely and done
differently but again that's me I'm not
in the business I'm not I'm not a
professional screenwriter I know how
hard job these guys are that doesn't
mean they're not susceptive to criticism
of course they are that's the job that
they got into but you know this isn't
the way I personally would have done the
film but I mean hey respect for trying
something different yeah and I mean I I
guess for me too part of it comes down
to like
Halloween kills did leave like a kind of
silly bad taste in my mouth so so for me
anything being better than Halloween
kills is probably like gonna grease my
wheels a little bit but I did think like
especially as compared to that movie I
thought the social commentary that movie
went for was quite clunky like that
movie exists on like a rinse repeat
cycle of like the same five lines of
dialogue that like all the characters
trade that's right evil dies tonight
I was watching the red letter Media
review again and they sort of said like
everyone in that movie talks like Loomis
and uh and I kind of yeah I feel like
it's a good way to sum that up and and
here I at least appreciated the the the
parts that were trying to be a little
more real life or at least show how you
might both cope with this and how other
people around you will cope with it also
and and that thing the guy said about
like people were taking my trauma and
making it about them like I thought this
movie had a much uh more
refined hand when doing those things it
felt like way more time was spent on
this script than was spent on Halloween
kills
um so yeah while it is not perfect I
thought it was at least a much more
smoothly paced experience minus a few
scenes that do feel like there are
scenes that cut abruptly and it feels
like it's a stylistic choice and then
there are other scenes that cut abruptly
where you feel like ah they probably
needed to trim time here
um but yeah I I was I was expecting part
way through some kind of weird twist
where it's like oh Michael's actually
been dead and Corey's just hallucinating
him or something like that and uh you
know it's interesting
to see how they like there were times
where I I thought they were setting us
up for that and I'm happy they didn't do
that ultimately I mean these movies
these blumhouse Halloween movies fall
somewhere in a weird Middle Ground where
it's like Michael's not Supernatural but
kind of I guess he's got at least the
power of superstition and whatever
physical force keeps him going
um but I did like again the
I'm conflicted about Michael living in
the sewer hole and like grabbing Corey
and you know kind of letting him go and
whatever he Matrix Tim he gave him all
his knowledge he did yeah yeah yeah and
and part of me at the end was like is he
gonna is the same thing gonna happen to
Lori all of a sudden like are they gonna
flirt again with like Rob Zombie
territory where it's like she's gonna
take up the mantle somehow
um but I I liked the actual like when we
really get late into the movie and
Michael is really the presence
um I liked just the way that they
captured him and the way that they you
know dealt with his face and The Mask
being off like when they have him pinned
to the the island in the kitchen uh it's
the Butcher Block like even that View
kind of up looking you can't see all of
his face and his mouth almost looks like
this gaping hole of sorts and uh and
yeah like there are images like that and
just general tone choices that I thought
were were quite nice that that built
upon that as aesthetic of the John
Carpenter movie scuzzed it up a little
bit more with you know some uh some 70s
esquino zombie-esque kind of
cinematography but and we'd be remiss to
not really quickly say even though you
already saw a reaction Corey had some
pretty gnarly kills I mean with the the
with Willie the kid where he stung up
and was just spinning around that I
think was the hardest it was the hardest
kill oh my and then the blow torch
through the kid's mouth oh my God
I mean yeah there were some definitely
inventive and uh definitely uh really
visual uh awesome kills in this so I
appreciated those for sure so I just
wanted to share some stuff I did enjoy I
didn't want you to think it was all bad
experience for me because it wasn't I
got to hang here with my buddy John got
to hang her with all you so it was
definitely a pleasurable experience
absolutely absolutely and I thought the
prologue was pretty solid I mean that's
a that's a pretty horrific scenario I
was not what I was expecting at all
oh my goodness yes I mean and they did
foreshadow with the camera like craning
up three different times like showing
how how uh steep the how high for that
zero was I mean and I even mentioned to
him like
that's a really scary stairwell
for good reason so yeah no that was
definitely one of the more unexpected
prologues as you would say in a
Halloween film for sure and that's the
thing I as I can definitely see that
not in the prologue specifically but
yeah like the Corey story as I've chosen
to call it I can see that being the the
um
the Genetically Enhanced Locus story
from Jurassic world for a lot of people
where it's like you know you have
dinosaurs and stuff in that movie but
we're gonna spend a lot of time on these
Locos we don't care about dinosaurs we
need Loki yeah and and that bothered me
uh the least actually about them I
didn't really mind that in fact I
thought that was fine and in this movie
though I could see a lot of people
coming in being like I came for Michael
Myers and I got this guy I could see a
lot of people saying that to him and I
guess one thing that Charmed me a little
about that is I thought it was a unique
way of playing on the requisite I feel
like at least Jason and Michael and
there's probably other slasher
franchises as well if they get deep
enough uh where you have your requisite
installment where it's not actually the
slasher character it's just an imposter
it's you know somebody who has a vague
connection to them somehow who has taken
up the mantle because of a psychotic
break and here I thought they did kind
of neatly to combine the two where it's
like yeah you have that element sort of
within Corey but you've still very much
got Michael and uh and I can see I'm
still teetering like I'm not 100 sure
how I feel about like the two of them
kind of working together and tag teaming
I'm like how did you guys coordinate
this did you do you just kind of know
I'm gonna meet you here Michael you meet
me over there uh let's just yeah at this
time you know how to read a clock and
all that right Michael we'll meet there
okay good yeah because like you know you
watch the Pitch meeting for for
Halloween kills and and it's like oh
yeah off camera Michael must be like
Dragon bodies around and like you know
setting stuff up and I can already see
the pitch me too and how does he get
Michael's mask I kind of presume it was
very hard actually it's very easy barely
an inconvenience he just pushes him over
oh okay yeah and I mean I guess you
could argue that they both have the
powerful which is why I know I'm just
I'm just projecting what I see from that
video in my pitch meeting video well and
I'm not even saying that's a good
explanation I'm just saying that yeah
like it must be the power nobody else
seems to be able to overpower Michael
Myers but I get yes because this kid is
snapped he he can do it
um but yeah I mean I overall I am
pleasantly surprised and I would say I
actually enjoyed this I mean there I
would go so far as to say their aspects
of this movie that might be my favorite
in the Blum House trilogy but I would
probably rank it second out of the three
I think the first one is the most solid
for sure this one again I was actually
I didn't know what to expect but I am
pleasantly surprised to have enjoyed it
quite as much as I did and then
Halloween kills is like way it's like
way down instead of that a three I'd put
it at like five because like that movie
drove me up a wall and so just to be
able to like enjoy this movie for the
most part was like a win for me
um and I thought all the actors were
well cast I think one thing people go
back and forth on David Gordon Green's
Halloween's approach to having Side
characters and stuff like that and
usually I will always welcome even if
characters just show up to die if
they're a little interesting or they
have some kind of Quirk about them I I
appreciate and enjoy that and so here
even if characters maybe didn't always
have the best motivation or maybe if
they weren't super fleshed out usually
minus like the doctor and the nurse who
had got the promotion or whatever uh
usually it seemed like the characters at
least were uh well inhabited by the
actors and and yeah I thought the the
different people who populated this
movie were at least a bit memorable and
brought you know a good amount of flavor
you know I could see the casting call
right now on the sheet must be the
biggest [ __ ] ever yeah bring your
bring your jerk face
yeah absolutely
um but good kills um the music
um what'd you think of the score uh from
John Carpenter this John Carpenter Cody
Carpenter and does I mean it's a John
Carpenter Cody Carpenter scoring no
complaints from me if anytime I get a
John Carpenter score I'm happy my heart
is you know I love the sounds of a John
Carpenter score and we got a beautiful
image of the fit John Carpenters the
thing that was so freaking awesome I'm
so glad I just watched that movie too of
like a month or two back so I could
understand what movie because I would
have hated myself if we would have
watched that scene I'd be like what
movie is that I see Kurt Russell what
movie is this I don't know well and in
the original aren't they watching the
thing from outer space yeah yeah so
there's a remake of which that's a cool
like Eastern Easter egg in an Easter egg
from an Easter egg now they're watching
the carpenter one oh holy [ __ ]
now now when they reboot Halloween one
day again then they're gonna watch the
the prequel to The Thing sure definitely
gotta just make it a three thing third
time's a charm baby 2011's the thing
dang well all right man any final
thoughts
um no it's just uh this was different uh
again I still thought there were moments
I really enjoyed again I respect that
they tried to do something different uh
there was a lot of subversion of
expectations which seems to be a big
Hollywood Trope nowadays like we're not
gonna do what you're expecting which is
fine again that doesn't mean I'm not
gonna like it just because what I'm
expecting was not in there it's all
about execution and is the storyline
interesting are some of the characters
fleshed out in a way that I feel you
know is makes the plot interesting and
just works uh with the actors as well
and again there were times in this I did
like in times in regards to is this a
top tier Hollywood Halloween film I
wouldn't go that far I would say it's
more on the middle the lower Spectrum
but again I still had a good time uh it
was a fun watch it was a fun reaction
um but uh yeah again respect for trying
to do something different yeah I would
put this prop I would actually probably
put this upper upper middle depending
because how many films deep are we now
we're quite deep I mean we got Halloween
1 Halloween 2 Halloween 3 season of the
witch Halloween for the return of
Michael Myers the fifth one is uh the
Revenge of Michael Myers the best one
ever and the curse of Michael Myers and
then H2O and then the best one ever by
Rick Rosenthal Resurrection then we got
Rob Zombie's 2007 version then we got
the Halloween sequel 2009 then we got
the 2018 then Halloween kills and then
we got this one so this is the 13th
movie I lost count when I was naming
them all or something yeah uh you know
what yeah I guess I would still put this
yeah pretty high mid I I mean I did
appreciate and I like Halloween H2O and
I love Halloween H2 and there was a lot
about that send-off that I I liked but I
did like the send-off like as much as
it's been inconsistent the way
Haddonfield thinks about and responds to
Michael over these three movies
especially acknowledging like it was
just a few murders in the 70s in that
first one and then completely 180inging
that sentiment for Halloween kills uh I
thought the send-off here were the whole
town Town gets together and they strap
him to the police car and they trash
compact him they they take him to the
junkyard like and just the way that was
captured and all the people kind of
opening up in in like the seas in front
of Moses as well he steps up and
everything like I thought all that stuff
was was pretty gripping and yeah I
thought the cast was good I thought uh
for the most part I liked at least that
they wanted to pay attention and to tell
a sort of Twisted story of people
bonding over and trying to alleviate
trauma I really liked Lori I liked the
bookends of her writing her book and
trying to move on and making that
conscious effort and even celebrating
Halloween and encouraging getting back
into normal life yeah for sure I mean
and she also she saw Rob Zombie's
Halloween too she saw how much Dr Loomis
profited off writing a book so she's
like I gotta get in on this action also
too I wish we would have saw the the
moment where you know that I'll admit
the image imagery was really cool where
the whole town came together to send off
Michael into the compactor like that was
great and all I love again the imagery
was great I just wish they would have
shown us everyone Michael Myers is dead
let's all come together and send him off
like where did they all come from like
they were all sleeping in there and I I
know it's a small town I get all that
but again she's some of these nip I'm
telling you CinemaSins is going to have
fun with this film and some of these
other channels they're gonna have a good
time with this movie oh I'll give them
I'll give them the stylistic not showing
us how we don't care but yes CinemaSins
well I mean yeah yeah but CinemaSins I'm
sure any slasher movie is is prime
fodder for for a show like that but uh
but yeah from for me is certainly not as
many as many nitpicks and even some
things that they they managed to win me
back over on so
um even if for a lot of people this
isn't like the satisfying definitive
ending I at least appreciate it being
an assured swing whereas the previous
movie did not feel like that
um I I feel like this one is at least a
swing and it's committed to what it's
swinging for and uh I got respect for
that fair enough so I don't know if I
agree with you on that so yeah people
what did you think of Halloween ends
what did you think of this blumhouse
Trilogy and how it complements the
original films what's your favorite
Halloween film leave us all your
Halloween related thoughts down below
and we will see you in a couple years
when they inevitably reboot the
franchise or make a sequel directly to
one of the other installments ignoring
several other installments
when that happens we'll be back but for
right now be well and we'll catch you
next time but not before we do a patreon
pandemic Jones pandemic you know what I
thought of during this movie they said
in the lead up uh when they were talking
about what they were going to be
tackling with this time Jump and they in
the Press stuff early on they made it
seem like it was going to be a way
bigger time Jump but they said it was
going to deal with the pandemic and it
didn't whatsoever uh but it made me
think of you pandemic Jones and how you
are the purest heart at our patreon if
anybody could go through what a guy like
Corey went through and not turn to the
dark side it's you buddy you got a kind
uh lovely demeanor and you have gentle
eyes that could never reflect evil and
we're glad to have you with us each and
every day evil is always dead when
pandemic Jones is around tonight or any
night doesn't matter and uh hey we love
you buddy stay pledged and we'll catch
you next month any any special words for
PJ sick name I love it hell's yeah
really cool dude be well and we'll catch
you next time
foreign